look at graphs shall we now to code X
plus 1 to connect upon the normal range
of contexts is 1 normally this is
actually really helpful I'd love you to
write the truth if you hadn't already
bad choice of color the regular range of
cause X is between negative 1 and 1
do you agree yes so now if I what the
range of two contexts will you multiply
the context by two so what's going to
happen to the item to Patras only you
also multiply two places so it will be
negative two to do but actually the
thing I dealing with is not true content
it's two Cod X plus one so in order to
have plus one well I just add one to
both of my feet I can't you see that you
see how I went from here to here and
then from here to here
exactly really really important
especially when we get to industries
later on so that's why I go from
negative 1 to 3 it's very important you
get these intercepts down here
and so that's why I've worked it out
down the bottom okay can we go over the
page already question how many rocks
would I lose if I don't have a sister
one and one okay these off these would
be oh okay here might be set so to find
the x-intercepts of anything do let y
for the earth because that's where all
the x intercept me of all the x axes
equation of which is y equals zero so I
let y equal 0 the equation of the line
is y equal to a 2 con squared - 2 cos x
plus 1 so I bet you connect sub 1 equals
0 that set my mind here I just have to
rearrange change the subject project
equals negative 1/2 and that's the basic
trigonometric equations we've been
dealing with over last week or so okay
so I got like two values of that
quadrant two quadrant three as you can
confirm by whipping up the gun
alright let's go to the page - Phoenix
that should be pretty straightforward
yes I am Rachel you there ok here's my
code six - extra so what I've done is I
do that Co SEC is the reciprocal of sine
right so if it's one on sine 2 X the
first thing I do is I draw sign to it
right that's my grave act is it in there
assign to it
I've got two copies of it because that's
what the 2x done from naught to 360 so
you see it waving up and down once
you've got sine 2x in place then you say
okay what's a boost of reciprocals like
there is some easy spot there is
difficult one is one and I've got
another copy there the reciprocal of
negative one is also negative one so
that's why you've got these two guys
down here after that you say well look
see how do you small values will the
reciprocal is going to be B and the
answer is a small negative value
well it's reciprocal will be a big
negative balance questions
if you didn't put the 45 you're probably
going to be okay so what if I can
clearly recognize all your bar top
concern recognized work that should be
halfway but you know it doesn't take
that much effort being put it on and
that way I'm I'm certain cool the vodka
can see I know what I'm doing
so if that wasn't there you can want to
get rid of it but I put their enemy are
you lost grass so there's collects
repaired this grass before you're
learning I live down this that's just
think me remember you give vertical
asymptotes whenever a denominator is
zero right that gives you vertical
denominator
I'm sorry vocalize research rather so I
know sightings really really well so I
know the places with my X is zero so I
put one two three vertical asymptotes
and then I spit the whisper glass around
down our dishes subscribe here we call
it our locking point for points is down
either this we do need one for this one
rather than the previous one where it
was ambiguous here you've definitely
definitely got to have it because if I
raise that this could just as easily
need to college for free clinics or
actually I take it back sorry you've got
are this scale over here which actually
means that this you actually have to
draw that quite actually so point five
but I've put it in anyway because hard
to see but that's exactly exactly
howdy nourishing how are they the same
that um you guys to remember bags okay
this is one over K Georgia can ex look
like and think about during the
reciprocal just like ideas for this
question
but beyond it's the quickest way for you
is to remember what they where you can
draw context of these controllers
clinics and then divide one by the other
backpacks really hard to clinical word
exponentially extension key whereas
looking at something routes reciprocal
studies from is considered attention to
absorb a blood disease think about like
a difficult one I can do that reciprocal
or the little come on it see that times
negative five questions pretty easy
that's it there's not really much thanks
online with no way this is a bit of a
I'm smoking gun seated in this remember
I told you you have what I on what
you're working on and the other island
where you're going you're going to zero
it's going to be something really simple
right so that's how I did I just you
know devolved down inside because other
room have but it would just be the
longer cared is the reciprocal cot so
tan x cot is one but they'll actually
not just a cocktail is this cotton hot
[ __ ] so one of them is left behind
okay